ya hemos hablado de la noción de
empleador monopolista en otros vídeos
pero vamos a repasar un poco el concepto
y vamos a introducir un pequeño giro y
el giro es qué pasa cuando tienen que
lidiar con un salario mínimo y como ya
hemos visto esto es un poco contra
intuitivo para empezar hagamos un repaso
un monopsonio es una situación donde
tienes un solo comprador y varios
vendedores de algo y cuando hablamos de
un empleador monopsonios está el
comprador es el comprador del trabajo
hablamos de comprador en los mercados
del factor del trabajo y los vendedores
son los trabajadores personas que venden
su trabajo por un salario
anteriormente hemos estudiado
situaciones con empleadores con opción
istas pero vamos a repasar nunca está de
más practicar de nuevo en el eje
vertical tenemos al salario que es
realmente el precio del factor trabajo
que estamos estudiando justo ahora y en
el eje horizontal tenemos la cantidad
del factor que nos importa esta es la
cantidad de trabajo ahora hemos visto
este escenario varias veces tienes tu
típica curva con pendiente decreciente
del ingreso marginal producto que
describe la situación donde cada unidad
adicional de trabajo que contrates el
ingreso adicional que obtengas baja y
baja y baja debido a que posiblemente
los rendimientos son decrecientes de
alguna forma esta es la curva del
ingreso marginal producto del trabajo
pero también podrías pensar en el
ingreso marginal producto del capital o
en el ingreso marginal producto de la
tierra
u otro factor
ahora pensemos también en la curva de
oferta del trabajo es más
pensemos en cuál es la curva del costo
marginal del factor y bueno es que si
este empleador no fuera mono option ista
es decir se operara en un mercado del
trabajo en competencia perfecta
entonces la curva del costo marginal del
factor sería el salario impuesto por el
mercado por lo que se vería algo así
pero como estamos trabajando con un
empleador monopolista entonces no toma
el salario del mercado ellos tienen una
curva de oferta del trabajo específica
porque recuerda ellos son el único
comprador en el pueblo tal vez ellos
sean los grandes empleadores en un
pueblo pequeño y por lo tanto tienes
esta curva de oferta oferta del trabajo
pero esta no es la curva del costo
marginal del factor ya lo hemos
explicado antes ya que si contratas
mayores y mayores cantidades de trabajo
necesitarás pagar mejor a las personas
adicionales que contrates pero lo que
realmente pasa es que si le pagas mejor
a una persona entonces tendrás que
pagarle a todos el mismo salario por lo
tanto si contratas unidades adicionales
de trabajo entonces no solo debes de
pagar más a esa unidad adicional debes
aumentar el salario actual
así que el costo marginal del factor irá
al doble de rápido que la curva de
oferta del trabajo por lo tanto la curva
del costo marginal del factor se va a
ver algo así
entonces es racional que la empresa se
mantenga con siguiendo estos factores en
este caso trabajo es decir se mantenga
contratando personal siempre que el
ingreso adicional de contratar a la
siguiente persona sea mayor que el costo
marginal o el costo adicional así que
nos vamos a mantener contratando
personas siempre que el mgp sea mayor
que el cmf hasta que lleguemos a este
punto de allí y por lo tanto será
racional para la empresa contratar esa
cantidad de personal
llamémosla q subíndice 1 ahora cuánto
les pagarán bueno pausa el vídeo y
piénsalo un poco porque esto siempre es
un poco complicado
bueno tal vez te sientas tentado a
dibujar una recta punteada aquí pero
recuerda esto no describe el salario
actual el salario para esa cantidad está
dada por la curva de oferta del trabajo
así que este será el salario de la
empresa que va a pagar w sub índice 1
así que ahora vamos a introducir un
pequeño giro vamos a pensar en qué pasa
si el salario mínimo se emplea en esta
región por alguna razón no sé el alcalde
de ese pueblo dice los trabajadores
necesitan que les paguen más dinero y
supongamos que instituye un salario
mínimo no sé w
índice m de mínimo que pondré en este
color pausa el vídeo y piensa un poco
qué pasa ahora cómo se ve la curva del
costo marginal del factor y cuál será la
cantidad racional de trabajo que deberá
contratar la empresa
muy bien ahora que en el pueblo se ha
instituido un salario mínimo y que es
superior al salario racional que de otra
manera la empresa pagaría por el trabajo
esencialmente lo que pasa es que al
menos en un cierto rango para la
cantidad de trabajo que se contrató el
empleador mont opción y sta tendrá que
pensar un poco como un empleador en un
mercado de trabajo competitivo donde
tienes que aceptar un salario impuesto
ahora este salario no es que se imponga
desde algún mercado se impone por el
gobierno entonces siempre que este
salario sea mayor que la oferta de
trabajo o mayor que la anterior curva de
oferta digámoslo así entonces esto será
desde la perspectiva de la empresa será
la nueva curva de oferta es decir se va
a ver algo así
después cuando los salarios que la curva
de oferta te escribe sean mayores que el
salario mínimo entonces va a seguir a la
curva de oferta antigua lo que nos dará
nuestra curva justo aquí esta es nuestra
nueva curva de oferta y claro hablamos
de la oferta de trabajo entonces cuál
será nuestra nueva curva de costo
marginal del factor bueno ya hemos dicho
que tiene el doble de la pendiente pero
la pendiente en este caso es horizontal
si usamos un nuevo color la curva de
costo marginal del factor va a seguir
esta recta horizontal de aquí y luego de
repente cuando la curva de oferta nueva
empieza a ascender nosotros brindaremos
a la anterior curva de costo marginal
del factor y entonces se verá algo así
podemos llamar a esta nueva curva como
la curva marginal factor
2 cmg efe 2
así le llamaré es decir esta curva azul
de nuevo va a seguir la curva de oferta
mientras se horizontal y realmente es
análogo a cuando tenemos que aceptar un
salario y después la curva bin acá
tenemos esta discontinuidad y después
seguimos acá arriba ahora lo racional
para la empresa será seguir contratando
siempre que el ingreso marginal producto
sea mayor que el costo marginal del
factor ya que nos mantendremos
contratando siempre que esta recta de
amarillo esté por arriba de la recta
azul entonces nos mantenemos contratando
nos mantenemos contratando hasta que
llegamos a este punto de aquí y observa
qué está pasando ahora es racional
contratar esta cantidad para la empresa
q subíndice 2 contratar más personas
pero esto parece contraintuitivo en el
día a día si me imagino que emprendo
algún tipo de negocio que emprendo no sé
hamburguesería y de repente me imponen
un salario mínimo mayor entonces parece
que no tendré suficiente dinero para
contratar trabajadores parece incluso
que podría disminuir el número de
personas que contraten pero hemos
mostrado de manera teórica que al menos
con este modelo económico muy
simplificado cuando hablamos de un
empleador monopsonio ésta en realidad
podría conseguir que contraten más
personas entonces la pregunta
interesante es por qué pasa esto que
parece contraintuitivo y un argumento
poco preciso pero te encargó que los
reflexiones es darse cuenta de que en el
antiguo escenario cada vez que ellos
trajeron una persona adicional ellos
tienen que aumentar el salario a todos
por eso obtenemos que el costo marginal
del factor creciera tan rápido pero
ahora que tenemos toda esta parte plana
de tu curva de oferta porque
independientemente de cuántas personas
contrates en este rango a todas ellas
tendrás que pagarles la misma cantidad
por cada persona adicional esta vez no
aumentaremos el salario de todos es por
esto que es racional para la empresa que
se mantenga contratando ahora la
comunidad el gobierno el alcalde del
pueblo tendrán que ser muy cuidadosos
sobre este salario mínimo porque es muy
posible que ellos puedan sobrepasar y en
realidad terminar en una situación donde
la empresa contrate - por ejemplo si
hacen a este salario mínimo
llamémosle w subíndice 3 entonces de
repente tienes una curva de costo
marginal del factor que va de esta
manera déjame escribirlo una curva
marginal factor y lo que pasa es que
seguimos más y más y más lejos a la
derecha pero ahora sólo será racional
para la empresa contratar esta cantidad
ha decrecido el empleo sin embargo si
regresamos a nuestra situación original
otra cosa que seguramente estás pensando
es hoy en esto parece demasiado bueno
para ser cierto ahora es racional para
la empresa contratar más personas y esas
personas obtienen un mayor ingreso
seguramente hay alguien que debe de
estar perdiendo y este es el caso donde
la empresa ahora va a perder más de él
podría decir excedente que lo que
perdería en el antiguo escenario y mucho
de eso se lo va a dar a los trabajadores